what there's a will there's a week and a
beautiful and everyone has its name so
magical is the obstacle that can't be
defeated for every tyrant until caught
we saw the balls of a miracle if we
dream a dream everybody in the world has
a chance today to say no only left me
broken Tuesday through with haben
Wednesday we should be announcing that
we're not replacing Trident at all and
that we're starting steps towards
getting rid of nuclear weapons
altogether
gradually the opinion of people in this
country is questioning the whole role of
a red eteri head of state
I feel very very sad that it's a Labour
Prime Minister that does so much now to
undermine the principles of the National
Health Service it's going to be
different and it's going to be better